So last time on True Fear I talked about the LA Sleepwalker.
If you haven't seen that video, click here and you can go check it out.
GO CHECK IT OUT!
So I never saw the LA Sleepwalker again, but I did make a habit of going out there to check to see if it was a habit.
That he was doing it every night or something.
He wasn't, but what I did notice was some other very strange things around my apartment complex.
Now, this was not a nice apartment by any standards.
But, it was student housing and it was close to school.
I wish I had never stayed there but there's nothing I can do about it now.
So anyways, there are all these closets scattered around the apartment complex,
and usually they're just closed and locked,
but when I got back one night from going to check for the sleepwalker,
I noticed that one of them was open.
And none of them have ever been open before,
so me and my roommates go to investigate, and we just find all of this crazy stuff inside of the closet.
Lawn chairs, cones, a shovel... just all of these random objects that anyone who lives in an apartment would never really need.
I don't remember all of the exact items though.
And the thing that was really weird about this was that none of our resident keys gave access to any of the closets.
So if these closets weren't for resident storage, who were they for?
So we decided to do a little investigating and check out all the doors in the apartment complex that didn't lead to other people's units.
Most of the closets were either locked or empty.
But we did discover two new doors that we could access.
One was at the end of our hallway,
which you can actually see here in Dead Air.
and the other one was on the hallway opposite of ours.
And they both led to these secret stairways.
Which probably weren't a secret to the stoners of this apartment building because they both smelled like weed.
The stairway closest to us had a doorway leading out to the side alley,
while the one on the other side did not.
We always thought that the main staircase, which you can see right here in Acrimonious,
was the only way to get up or down in the building, because whatever labels that had been on these stairwells
to tell you that they were stairs,
had been torn off.
But the most important part was at the top of each stairwell there were two doors.
One leading back to the resident hallways, and one leading to... we don't know what.
So we wanted to figure out what these other doors led to.
At the top of the staircase closest to us, the door was locked.
But on the other side, it was open.
Behind the door, there's this tiny closet,
and in the back of the closet there's this metal hatch.
About 2' x 2'.
So we open the hatch and it leads to this chute.
We look down in the chute, and there's this secret room underneath.
And we had no idea how to access this room from the rest of the building.
And we had no idea that it existed before.
So I poked my head down there and it was pitch black,
but with the help of a phone light, we were able to see a few things.
There were some boxes, some canned food, and a sleeping bag.
So I immediately pulled my light out of there,
because what's going through my head is there's someone living down there,
and if they see the light, they're probably going to walk underneath and look back at us.
And if something like that did happen,
I imagine the person would probably be enraged that we found out that they were living down there.
Because, let's face it, the management to that building, however lazy they may be,
probably wouldn't be too happy if there was someone secretly living inside,
and they would be likely to investigate.
Actually on second thought, that management literally didn't care about us at all..
but that would be considered trespassing if somebody was down there,
so if somebody found out they could potentially get the police involved.
Think about if you were living down there and somebody found out about you.
That's potentially threatening your entire existence.
Your entire way of living.
You would probably want to do something about it.
And I know that sounds kind of overdramatic, but you have to keep in mind that these people on the streets in LA are there for a reason.
It's a sad reality, but you see a lot of people who are mentally ill, or at least mentally unstable.
So honestly the idea of somebody seeing us and coming after us was not entirely out of the question.
Especially considering the fact that we had nowhere to hide, because
they know that we live in those apartments.
And they could easily follow us back or lurk by the entrance until we go in or out.
And I know this whole thing might sound a little over the top
considering we had no actual evidence that anyone was living down there,
just a top-down view of some canned food and a sleeping bag,
but you have to remember that I have a very dark imagination and there was enough evidence to at least confirm that there was SOMETHING going on.
So we went back to our apartment and started discussing what we had seen,
and thus, the idea of The Hobo King was born.
...Or at least... it started as just an idea...
Being creative people, we came up with this whole scenario and character revolving around The Hobo King.
In our story, The Hobo King is actually a very smart man who figured out how to live his life safely and efficiently
without needing to get a job
and has sinced reached out to other homeless people in the area to give them a shelter overnight.
So he dubbed himself The Hobo King and started donning tattered robes made up of rags
and one of those Burger King birthday crowns that he found in the dumpster.
He's a very egotistical character.
So over time he amassed all of these followers.
And he gave them a place to stay in exchange for collecting taxes from the people off the streets.
So if you're homeless, and you want to stay in The Hobo King's "castle" if you will,
you could do so by giving him 20% of the earnings that you made begging by the freeway ramp.
So that's the extent of what we made up.
The rest of this is all real.
I'll still be referring to the homeless person as The Hobo King for the rest of the story though.
So from that point forward, we started checking up on the closets
and monitoring what was going on on the property after the staff left every night.
What we found, was that while all the closets are usually locked,
every now and then, a random one of them would be left open.
And we would just find more weird things inside.
But that one door at the end of the staircase that led to the chute was always open.
We think that somebody left it open a while ago,
one of the staff members, and perhaps forgot about it and it's just been left open ever since.
But the question still remained:
How was The Hobo King getting access to this supposedly gated property?
Who was the one getting inside and granting access to all of these doors and closets?
To answer that, we looked at the three types of people who have access to the property:
The residents, the managers, and the maintenance guy.
Anyone else who came onto the property, like pest control for example,
was an independent worker and didn't have access to anything.
As I mentioned earlier, as residents, we didn't have access to any of those doors because none of our keys worked on them.
So that just left the manager and the maintenance guy.
Both of them were absolutely awful.
The manager would really only stop in for about an hour every day to meet with potential leasers
and then leave right after that.
We know this because whenever we had a problem and we tried to get ahold of the manager,
it was impossible and we would end up just having to wait around all day by the manager's office.
That just leaves us with the maintenance guy
who was abhorrently lazy.
Whenever we had an issue, he would just show up like a week later with one of his friends.
Yes, he would just bring some of his friends to work with him sometimes.
We would tell him about the problem we were having,
he would be like, "oh, OK, I'll be right back,"
and then he would leave and never come back.
But we did notice that he would spend a lot of time behind closed doors in his office
talking to one of his friends that he had brought to work
which led me to this theory.
One of the maintenance guy's friends is The Hobo King.
The maintenance guy feels bad for him,
and leaves him open a closet or room to stay in each night.
After The Hobo King gains some followers,
he convinces the maintenance guy to let a few of them stay as well.
Over time, it leads to an infestation.
This theory is backed up because during the day, when the maintenance guy was in,
is when all the locks would get changed.
Which was also when we were away at class.
We would also see the maintenance guy roaming around with a huge key ring
with dozens and dozens of keys.
And finally, the maintenance guy was always in his office,
but he was never actually out maintaining or fixing anything.
We continued to keep tabs on all the activity that was taking place around the apartment complex.
But what we really wanted to know was how to access that secret room.
With the exception of opening the hatch, throwing a rope, and climbing down.
And then being stuck down there with a potentially crazy homeless person.
And no exit.
We assumed that the chute, and another chute that we assumed also exists on the stairwell by our side,
were both garbage chutes at one time
that they just got too lazy to keep taking to the street,
and then moved the dumpsters to the street for us to take our garbage out to.
If that's true, then there had to be an entrance somewhere,
most likely in the two alleyways on either side of the building.
First, we checked the alleyway on our side.
We didn't find a secret door on our side, but we did find
all these SCUBA books and SCUBA equipment that had just been scattered out in the alley for some reason...
I really don't know what to make of that.
That doesn't even have to do with the story at all.
But I just thought I'd throw that in there.
We had to hop a fence to access the alleyway on the other side.
A fence that seemed to be guarding nothing but an empty alleyway.
Until we found a door on the side of the building that lined up with the exact location where the secret room should be.
We were actually pretty nervous to go inside, because what if there was a homeless person living in there right now?
But, we wanted answers, so we decided to just quietly go inside and see if there was anything going on in there.
So I go down the alleyway to open the door.
My roommates get ready to run, if need be.
I turn the handle and...
the door's locked.
But here's the thing,
we don't know if it's locked from the inside or the outside,
so just to play it safe, we book it.
All the way back to the other side.
All the way back until we're safe inside of our apartment.
So for a while we're just sitting there discussing it and kind of building on the lore of The Hobo King.
So in the apartment we have this big rear-projection TV.
While we were talking, I kept looking over at the window because I felt like I saw something moving.
And I should add that the window leads to the alleyway on our side.
And then at one point I thought I saw something on the TV.
But the TV was off.
This was a reflection.
And in the reflection, I see the outline of a man's head staring through the window.
I look over to the window and the man's gone.
I look back to the TV to see if it was maybe something else, and whatever it was, was gone.
All I can see in the reflection is the empty window.
Now I'm not going to immediately cry Hobo King, because we did make that character up,
but I don't think it's out of the question to suggest that there may have been someone living in the building.
Or maybe not.
I mean, we had a neighbor who lived next to us, who had somebody break in through his window.
So it really could have been anybody.
But there is one more chapter to this story.
We didn't end up staying at the apartment complex much longer than that.
And no, we did not leave because of The Hobo King,
but basically what happened is there was this leak in our ceiling,
and the maintenance guy was too lazy to fix it,
and it turned into a hole in the ceiling,
and once the hole formed in the ceiling we got bed bugs,
and it was just this whole huge disaster.
The bed bugs were a fate far worse than any Hobo King.
Or really far worse than anything at all.
It was an awful experience.
But that's a whole nother story.
But anyways, we were kind of getting over the whole Hobo King thing,
because we hadn't seen anything in a while,
but before we left, we were walking around and noticed that there was one more closet door that had been left open.
And it wasn't one that we had previously seen open at any time before.
So we opened it.
There were some electrical panels, wires and switches, a potted plant...
But on the floor...
There was a blanket and pillow.
And it wasn't like they were folded up and stored in the corner,
they were laid out like an actual bed.
But the craziest part of any of this, was in the closet there was a bunch a graffiti on the walls.
And they were mostly just like, "so and so was here," and pictures of penises and what have you,
but there was this one little bit of text that completely blew my mind.
It said: King.
So as we were filming this, my buddy WestDakota, who's helping me film these videos,
actually mentioned that he has a little bit more information that I wasn't even aware of,
so I'm gonna hand it over to him.
So this apartment complex ended the contract with our school due to a whole slew of issues,
but a couple months before that contract ended, hanging up around the complex were signs
telling the residents to make sure that the gates were closed
because there were a bunch of homeless people getting into the complex
and sleeping in the closets you've been told about,
so that just confirms the story a little bit more about how there were homeless people staying in this apartment complex.
And I didn't even know that going into this.
I just asked Dakota to come to help me make a video.
He didn't know that I was recording this at all,
and he'd just happened to stumble upon that little bit of information.
This was the last of what I have to tell about The Hobo King.
I was actually working on a found footage web-series for a while based on our apartment complex and
our idea of what The Hobo King might be.
It included characters that represented each of us, as well as some new made up characters.
Sadly I never got to shoot it before the bed bugs forced us out of that place
and the script really did rely on the geographical layout of that complex.
However...
After the bed bugs, we found ourselves hopping around from hotel to hotel for a while.
So on the next episode of True Fear, I'll be telling you guys about the crazy woman in one of the rooms.
There's a crazy woman in one of the rooms!
Leave your own theories about The Hobo King in the comments.
If we get 200 likes on this video, I will read you guys the script for my found-footage web-series about The Hobo King
Either here, or on my other series, Al Dente Creepypasta,
so make sure to share this video, get it out there, get it some likes,
and as always don't forget to subscribe and I will see you in the next video.
Assuming we both survive.